si vede bene ragazzi veramente questo
video sono fra i geni come potete vedere
se non è la mia storica location
torinese che questa è la mia è la mia
camera con nella quale iniziato a fare i
video nel caso non lo sapeste dovreste
saperlo dal mash up del video dell'altro
ieri scusatemi se questo video un po
fatto così ma sto facendo il video col
telefono appunto sto facendo video col
telefono perché sono venuto sono tornato
a torino a casa mia per le vacanze di
natale perché voglio stare un po con i
miei genitori
sto usando il telefono per pare non
perché non mi merito 5 milioni di
iscritti
ma perché a casa mia qua dovevo facevo i
video all'inizio non ho più il setup per
fare i video quindi scusatemi se fa un
po schifo l'unica cosa che è cambiata di
questa splendida cameretta nel tempo e
che adesso cioè quell elemento lì che mi
no non è vero
no non ci credo dai ma che schifo ma
veramente questo schifo che schifo ma
piccià nel pannolino perché hai fatto
questa cosa ma vi giuro che non lo
faceva da da secoli non piaceva per
terra ai pisciato sempre nel pannolino
cosa fai delle regredisce
comunque sì bravo in grammatica comunque
sono qui perché volevo dirvi un paio di
cose oggi un video normale volevo farvi
volumi di b2 tre nomi importanti
innanzitutto volevo ringraziarvi per il
successo che ha avuto lo speciale perché
siamo arrivati a lato registrando questo
video 24 ore dopo la pubblicazione dello
speciale e siamo arrivati in 24 ore
quindi un giorno intero ad un milione di
incredibile non ho mai credo fatto un
milione di views invidui 24 ore se non
haters in italia che è commemorato sul
mio sul mio muro intanto si sta come si
sta commettendo un cani cidio qua però
facciamo finta di niente
siamo arrivati a un milione di views ed
è un video lo speciale un video non
musicale perché i tassi in italia telari
a scott il uniti riguardi video
facilmente lo speciale non è un video
musicale quindi il milione di views
nello speciale vale di più di quello di
mettersi in italia e ventilatore perché
è un video di 15 minuti incredibile che
sia stato visto così tanto vi ringrazio
davvero non mi aspettavo assolutamente
questo successo per quanto mi aspettavo
andasse bene ma cavoli così tanto sono
veramente contento vi ringrazio davvero
dal più profondo del cuore ho pensato
all'inizio pensavo di fare un video più
commemorativo della serie vi ringrazio
per i cinque i rischi poi mi sono
accorto che è se dovessi fare un video
ringraziamento per i 5000 iscritti come
sempre dopo un minuto che ringrazio voi
vi siete già martellati gioielli che la
metà basta giustamente quindi ho detto
va bene facciamo qualcosa di gli ho
detto abbia facciamo un qualcosa di
divertente e abbiamo ragionato appunto
tutti questi vip che ringrazio tra
l'altro e abbiamo girato appunto il
video è stato ci siamo fatti un mazzo
tanto se non l'avete ancora visto andato
a vedervi lo speciale 5 milioni ieri non
ho fatto video perché volevo lasciare
volevo prendermi un giorno di pausa
perché per fare quello speciale vi
assicuro che ci abbiamo messo un mese
tra regia registrazione montaggio una
pena incredibile quindi mi sono preso un
giorno di pausa per chiaramente stavo
morendo e niente che mi sono venuto a
torino
adesso sono qua con la mia famiglia
trascorrerò le vacanze qui e tornerò poi
a milano verso il 3 gennaio più o meno
faccio questo video per informarvi
appunto di un paio di cose la prima
stasera ci dovrebbe essere la live live
del lunedì che non ci sarà perché
siccome sono a torino sono trovata a
casa mia
connessione per fare le live e quindi le
live riprenderanno quando tornerò a
milano quindi alive sono interrotte fino
al 7 gennaio se non sbaglio il 7 gennaio
e lunedì dove riprenderò fare live
normali fino al 7 gennaio quindi non ci
saranno live serali perdonatemi ragazzi
ma quanno nola con no rega non c'è posto
non ho la connessione che mi permette di
fare live prova di premi un attimino di
pausa anche io sono qua per dirvi 23
robe caro alla prima da gennaio inizierò
a registrare il famosissimo esperimento
incredibile esperimenti incredibile
perché lo conoscesse sarebbe la seconda
serie originale poi la prima è un box in
valigia è già iniziata che sta andando
molto bene infatti vi ringrazio chi
inizierà esperimenti incredibile che si
tratta di esperimenti
mamma mia non avreste mai detto e no no
no no no no no il fazzoletto ma dove
l'hai preso non sa il fazzoletto no e
quindi da quando pubblicherò esperimenti
incredibile a settimana sarà composta da
lunedì giovedì le serie a con le live
martedì unboxing fa vj mercoledì
gameplay normale giovedì esperimento
incredibile quindi preparatevi perché ci
sarà questo non mi spiega che cosa sta
facendo quella fare lì qualcuno mi
spiega che calze o perché ecco bravo
perché perché
inoltre ragazzi in questi giorni
usciranno video della madonna perché da
domani si riparte normalmente per farvi
un esempio non so se vi ricordate il
candelabro ma non con marco ecco abbiamo
registrato una cosa che secondo me è
quello il candelabro è è un tutorial in
confronto quindi non avete idea di casa
per uscire sul canale vedrete quindi
ragazzi cosa volevo dirvi volevo dirvi
che stanno per uscire contenuti veri
power
quindi no vabbè ma non è posto ma tutto
lei ma mentre sto registrando ma ma
preme tema tutto adesso non potevi
cagare stamattina niente niente la mia
vita qui va beh devo tagliare corto
perché qua sai mi sta implodendo il cane
spero che
lo speciale vi sia piaciuto vi ricordo
se non l'avete visto trovate il link in
descrizione mi scuso appunto se ieri non
un fatto video per un giorno perché
facevo un po riprendermi e niente volevo
augurarvi di persona
buone feste passate le con i vostri
genitori riguardate tutti insieme il
video speciale che ci siamo fatti un
mazzo così per farlo volevo veramente
ringraziarvi quindi di cuore per il
traguardo dei 5 milioni ragazzi sono
veramente tanti 5 milioni siamo
veramente tantissimi però come ho detto
nel video speciale non è tanto il
traguardo in sé dei 5 milioni quanto il
percorso che abbiamo fatto c'è il
divertimento che c'è stato insieme per
me significa avere conosciuto tante
persone durante il mio percorso persone
che mi hanno arricchito a livello
proprio personale livello culturale a
livello di milan so ma mi hanno formato
io cerco di prendere un po il meglio
delle persone quando le conosco da
domani
ricominciamo i video normali spero che
ai video vi sia piaciuto mi spieghi che
cosa stai facendo non raga io ve lo
giuro non lo capisco ma cosa fa è pazzo
stamattina non è un demonio ma ora che
non fa non fa mai così ma cosa stai
facendo esattamente da un'ora e mezza
non raga ve lo giuro non so cosa sia
succedendo da stamattina che ho al tipo
di fatto della pockaj non lo so però
chiudo perché devo fare cose devo pulire
kaki e fare robe propria video vi sia
piaciuto sudate mila la rozzezza di
queste riprese perché lo stato veramente
l'ho fatto col telefono suo video però
non ho materiale quattro i genitori
tranquilli
da adesso inizia di vita normale quindi
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto come
al solito subito è piaciuto al suo
commento è un mi piace anche i vari
social che come noi video tradizione se
non sono restii schietti e noi ci
rivediamo ad una prossima cagata per
terra bella ragazzi
[Musica]